because Claire Foy you get quite an
emotional reaction from fans don't you
not so much fans but one lady I met a
lady who I really enjoyed meeting you
can I just say to her where oh she's not
in the audience if you smelled vinegar
she's nearly the chip shop and a woman
came in and we started chatting because
we were wait they were you know
battering our court we're having a chat
and she put on at in today and she was a
bit drunk and she was talking about how
kind of gone very well but hopefully
they were gonna be friends
my mum facetimed me and for some reason
me picking up my iphone and talking to
my mother reminded her of the Queen I'm
ended the call with my mum
and she went oh I love you so much I
love you so much and I think it was a
combination between the chat we'd had
previously the tinder date the alcohol
the chip shop element but it was quite
we cuddled that was it was a special
moment for me as well to find a member
of the royal family in Egypt that is a
cheering thing and it's very quickly
season 2 of the crowd everybody very
excited
[Applause]
we all we all of the better I'm so this
is already your last stint that's it
yeah it's over why would you do that
that's it I'm done but couldn't you talk
to another season were you always always
yeah yeah I thought you supposed to know
no no we always knew it was only gonna
be two series so I'm completely from
from the beginning it's always been what
I've known and that then the part is
reincarnated and someone else go goes
well that's the nature of the part
Queens like bond essential do you know
who's stepping into the ground now yes I
do
no no yes is it yes somebody famous for
a living okay so a professional actor is
going to play the role
[Laughter]
all right move on No
did we get us anywhere I'm told you know
but your husband Greg's in it so does he
not oh yeah oh yes he's in it yes yes
he's in it he's Mountbatten it's good
it's good but of course what's odd of
course is you have also played the Queen
oh yes I have not as well as Claire I
have to tell you look at my face slapped
our care is so good in it you said there
are some kind of little tricks you use
like the voice you have a little trick
for the voice well I'm a monk Union
originally and the only thing I've kept
is how I pronounce one which as I say
one which is completely wrong and it
took me about five months of just
drilling of going one as opposed to a
ward every once in a while Matt had his
own whole situation with was and the
curls and all whistles but but one I'm
losing already I heard if you feel her
going yeah but I really had to just
every time before doing take a still
Wade you know I mean that when she does
that
afternoon speeches at Christmas it's
like going back in time you just go duh
how does anyone still speak didn't I
mean if she does the same thing maybe
[Applause]
[Music]